♪ ♪
>> Greg: REMEMBER WHEN THE
NEW YORK MAYOR OR FREED A BUNCH
OF INMATES BECAUSE HE FEARED
THEY MIGHT GET THE CORONAVIRUS?
HE VICTIMIZED THE NAIVE
CIVILIANS WHO ELECTED HIM.
SO, HOW DID THIS GARMENT BAG OF
DIRT RESPOND?
"I THINK IT’S ON A HUMAN LEVEL
THAT FOLKS WOULD SHOW MERCY AND
THIS IS WHAT SOME OF THEM HAVE
DONE."
SHOCKER.
THEY WERE DEEPLY HURT THAT THE
MIRROR FOUND THERE ACTIONS
UNCONSCIONABLE AND THEY’S WORK
FROM ON THAT THEY WILL NEVER
STEAL AGAIN.
HE WILL TAKE THE OFFER AFTER HE
HITS THE GYM ACROSS TOWN.
I NORMALLY AVOID AD HOMINEM
ATTACKS, BUT HE IS NOT AN ACTUAL
HOMONYM.
HE’S A WALKING STACK OF STUPID.
LIKE JUNGLE WITH FEET.
HE IS LITERALLY THE BIGGEST JOKE
IN AMERICAN POLITICS.
IN THE NATION OF ADULTS, WE ARE
RULED BY IDIOT CHILDREN WHO
CHOOSE TO IGNORE THE LINKS
BETWEEN ACTIONS AND
CONSEQUENCES.
REMEMBER, AS THE CORONAVIRUS
SPREAD, HE EMPLOYED PEOPLE TO
LEAD NORMAL LIVES.
AND NOW, HIS OWN ACTIONS SPREAD
CRIME LIKE A VIRUS.
CITIZENS SEE OTHERS FAILING TO
SOCIAL DISTANCE.
>> WHEN YOU SEE A CROWD, WHEN
YOU SEE LINE WHERE THERE IS NO
DISTANCE, WHEN YOU SEE A
SUPERMARKET, YOU CAN REPORTED SO
THAT WE CAN GET HELP THERE TO
FIX THE PROBLEM.
IT’S AS SIMPLE AS TAKING A
PHOTO.
ALL YOU GOT TO DO IS TAKE THE
PHOTO AND PUT THE LOCATION WITH
IT, AND BANG, SEND A PHOTO LIKE
THIS, AND WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
THE ENFORCEMENT COMES RIGHT
AWAY.
>> Greg: WOW.
SO, FIRST HE TELLS PEOPLE TO
IGNORE THE VIRUS.
THEN, HE SENDS DOGS ON THE CITY.
THEN HE ASKS FELLOW CITIZENS.
WHAT A CREEP.
SOMEONE SHOULD TAKE A PICTURE OF
HIM AND HANG IT AT EVERY
POST OFFICE.
THE NUMBER ONE MOST UNWANTED
MIRROR OR TOSS IT IN THE BOTTOM
OF A AND FLATTER HIM.
I WOULD SAY LOCK HIM UP, BUT HE
WOULD ONLY RELEASE HIMSELF TO A
PARADE THAT HE ARRANGED.
ALL RIGHT, JUAN, THIS IS A CITY.
I THINK I KNOW THE PROBLEM HERE.
THIS IS A CITY IN WHICH THE
POLITICIANS DON’T HAVE A HEALTHY
OPPOSITION.
SO, THE WEAKER INCOMPETENT
CANDIDATES CAN STRETCH THE
LIMITS OF THEIR OWN FAILURES.
BECAUSE THERE IS NO NORMAL
MODERATES DEMOCRAT LAUGHS.
BEFORE YOU GOT A POINT.
I DON’T LIKE ANY CITY THAT LACKS
THAT KIND OF POLITICAL TENSION
AND A LOT OF THE BIG CITIES ARE
NOW IN A SITUATION WHERE YOU
HAVE DEMOCRATS WHO JUST RULED.
I THINK YOU’VE GOT TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF CHALLENGE.
I MEAN, IT’S INTERESTING.
IN NEW YORK, ALEXANDRIA COSSEY
OR CORTEZ NOW A MORE
CONSERVATIVE DEMOCRAT WILLING TO
RUN AGAINST HER.
TO YOUR POINT, I THINK IT’S A
REAL PROBLEM FOR US AS AN
AMERICAN PEOPLE RULED BY A
CONSTITUTION THAT SAYS NO CRUEL
AND UNUSUAL PUNISHMENT.
WHAT DO WE DO WITH PEOPLE WHO
ARE IMPRISONED WHICH OFTEN TIMES
CAN BECOME A PETRI DISH FOR THE
SPREAD OF DISEASE?
SO, YOU DON’T WANT TO SAY, HEY,
YOU ARE CONDEMNED AND YOU HAVE
TO STAY THERE, ESPECIALLY IF YOU
ARE NOT CHARGED WITH A VIOLENT
CRIME.
BUT THEN WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY
DO GET OUT AND COMMIT ANOTHER
CRIME BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO SAY, HEY, YOU LET THAT GUY
BACK OUT ON THE STREET.
BUT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE, I
THINK, LOOK, NEW YORK’S CRIME
RATE HAS NOT GONE UP.
IT’S GONE DOWN SINCE WE’VE GONE
INTO SHELTERING TO PROTECT
OURSELVES AGAINST THE VIRUS.
IN FACT, THIS IS A GLOBAL
REALITY.
CRIME HAS GONE DOWN AND I THINK
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THAT IN MIND.
>> Greg: OKAY, SO THERE IS A
SOLUTION FROM ADJUSTED.
DO REMEMBER SHERIFF ARPAIO?
INSTEAD OF SAYING LET THEM GO,
WHY CAN’T YOU BUILD A TEMPORARY
PLACE?
I MEAN, IT’S BEEN DONE.
>> Jesse: YEAH, DIDN’T HE MAKE
HIM WEAR PINK UNDERWEAR?
THAT WAS HIM AT HIS BEST.
I REMEMBER THAT GUY.
I MEAN, COME ON.
CRIMINALS COMMIT CRIMES.
SHOCKING REVELATION, MAYOR OR.
SOON HE’S GOING TO FIND OUT THAT
BABIES CRY AND WOMEN ARE JEALOUS
THAT FAT PEOPLE LIKE TO EAT.
IS THIS HIS FIRST DAY ON PLANET
EARTH?
HE’S LIKE A PARENT THAT LEAVES
HIS TEENAGE SON ALONE ON THE
WEEKEND COMES BACK AND CAN’T
BELIEVE HE THREW A PARTY.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT?
LOOK, IF I WAS THE MAYOR AND
THERE WAS A AN OUTBREAK IN THE
PRISON, WHAT I RELEASE EVERYONE
FROM THE PRISON?
NO.
THERE IS SHELTERING IN PRISON.
I WOULD KEEP THEM THERE, I WOULD
TREAT THEM, AND THAT WOULD TEST
AND TREAT THE GUARDS.
IT’S NOT THAT CRAZY.
THE OTHER THING IS TOO, THE
KNOCKING THING.
YOU CALL IT A THING.
THIS GUY SAYS DON’T GO TO JIM’S
AND WORK IN THIS PANDEMIC.
THE NEXT DAY HE WAS PHOTOGRAPHED
AT THE GYM WORKING OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT HIS EXCUSE WAS?
WELL, ON THE MAYOR SO I HAVE TO
STAY IN SHAPE AND BE HEALTHY TO
GUIDE THE CITY.
THE GOVERNOR TOTALLY ECLIPSED
HIM.
>> Greg: I AGREE WITH ALMOST
EVERYTHING YOU SAY, BUT I WILL
SAY THAT MEN CAN OFTEN GET
JEALOUS AND SKINNY PEOPLE LIKE
TO EAT TOO.
>> Jesse: MORE JEALOUS.
MORE JEALOUS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: I MAY BE THE MOST
INSECURE PERSON.
>> Juan: I THINK GREG SAVED
YOU, JESSIE.
HE’S HOLDING YOUR HAND.
>> YEAH, I WAS GET READY TO GO.
I WAS GETTING READY TO GO.
>> Jesse: I’M LIKE GREG.
I DON’T MAKE ATTACKS.
>> Greg: YOU JUST MAKE BLANKET
STATEMENTS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THE MAYOR WANTS TO HAVE
PARADE AND I KNOW IT’S A NOBLE
THOUGHT FOR RESPONDERS AND
HOSPITAL STAFF, BUT IS IT REALLY
WIDE TO HAVE MASSIVE EVENTS ONCE
YOU REOPEN THE CITY?
>> YOU JUST HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED IN ST. LOUIS IN
PHILADELPHIA AFTER 1918, THE
SPANISH FLU.
PHILADELPHIA HAD A MASSIVE SPIKE
IN CASES AGAIN AND A LOT OF
DEATHS OCCURRED.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE PRISON
POPULATION AND PEOPLE BEING
RE-OFFENDERS, I MEAN, THE 2018
BUREAU OF JUSTICE STATISTICS
ACTUALLY SAID THAT ABOUT SIX TO
8% OF PEOPLE RELEASED FROM
PRISON WILL GET PUT BACK IN FOR
THREE YEARS FOR COMMITTING A NEW
CRIME.
IT’S NOT EVEN LIKE THEY FLIPPED
LIKE CRIME WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE
WERE GOING TO COMMIT CRIMES
AGAIN.
WE NEED TO BE SMARTER ABOUT
THIS.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, DANA, I
THINK THAT DE BLASIO’S SUCCESS
IS BASED ON ALL THE WORK THAT
WAS DONE BEFORE HIM WITH
BLOOMBERG AND GIULIANI.
IT’S LIKE THEY GAVE HIM AN
EXPENSE ACCOUNT OF A HEALTHY
CITY AND HE’S JUST SPENDING IT
EVERYWHERE.
HE’S GOT SO MUCH TO WORK WITH.
>> Dana: YEAH, HE’S THAT GUY
ON, IN A BIKE RACE THAT JUST
CUTS IN BEHIND THE LEADER AND
COASTS RIGHT THROUGH.
HE’S PROBABLY ONE OF THE --
I HAVEN’T SEEN THE NUMBERS, BUT
MOST MAYOR ’S APPROVAL RATINGS
HAVE GONE WAY UP ACROSS THE
BOARD, BUT I THINK HE’S PROBABLY
THE NATION’S WORST MAYOR, I
THINK.
I THINK IT IS FAIR TO SAY THAT.
I DON’T KNOW IF THAT’S A BLANKET
STATEMENT OR AN AD HOMINEM
ATTACK.
I JUST THINK IT’S AN ATTACK.
>> Greg: ONE DANA, THE NICEST
PERSON ON EARTH SAYS YOU ARE THE
WORST MAYOR OR IN THE
UNITED STATES, IT’S PROBABLY